Hola Bienvenidos a una semana en el
mundo el programa de France 24 en el que
los periodistas son los invitados y Con
quienes conversamos de manera un poco
más distensionada sobre algunos de los
hechos más destacados de la semana para
conversar sobre la selección de temas
que tenemos para el programa de hoy
hemos invitado a Rafael Manzano
periodista internacional en W radio
Colombia Rafael Bienvenido al programa
Qué tal termina su semana
Pues
razonadamente bien Santiago
razonablemente bien paso a preguntarle
ahora a Gonzalo baños periodista editor
internacional en todo noticias TV
Argentina Bienvenido al programa Gonzalo
Y qué tal termina usted su semana
bien por suerte aquí en Argentina lo
estamos terminando un tanto
convulsionado como acostumbra a ser
Argentina pero también muy bien por
suerte Bueno ya hablaremos justamente de
su país y aquí en el estudio de France
24 nos acompaña Kelly cabana ella es
periodista enfocada en temas
internacionales en RCN radio en Colombia
también es especialista en conflictos
que Li Bienvenida al programa y qué tal
termina usted su semana Santiago Muchas
gracias por la invitación una semana
agitada obviamente un poco de crispación
algunas reformas que pasaron otras que
no pero bueno bien trabajando bueno
Recuerden que ustedes también hacen
parte de este debate y esta conversación
pueden dejar sus opiniones comentarios y
preguntas en nuestras redes sociales nos
encuentran como
@frans24_es antilogo que es mi cuenta
personal y nuestra etiqueta es numeral
una semana en el mundo f24 todo junto
todo pegado para que dejen ustedes sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales comenzamos con nuestro primer
tema destacado de la semana hace poco
más un mes que Turquía y Siria Fueron
sacudidas por una serie de terremotos
que provocaron el colapso de miles de
edificaciones pero también la muerte de
cerca de 53.000 personas a las que se
suman miles de heridos un mes después el
gobierno Turco ha sido fuertemente
criticado por esa lenta respuesta dada
para atender esta emergencia y también
para brindar ayuda a los damnificados
recordemos que estos terremotos
ocurrieron en medio del Invierno boreal
por lo tanto estas zonas afectadas se
enfrentan bajas temperaturas y también
Nevadas Aunque pues ya la primavera está
prácticamente a la vuelta de la esquina
las deficiencias en las especificaciones
de las construcciones el clima el inicio
de la carrera presidencial la crisis
económica son solamente algunos factores
que se conjugan en una especie de
Tormenta perfecta que afecta al
presidente allí verdogan quien aspira a
ser reelecto comienzo aquí en el estudio
de France 24 Kelly impresiones que deja
este mes después de este de estos
devastadores terremotos allí en Turquía
y lo que significa esto de Cara a esas
elecciones presidenciales muy difícil
sobre todo no Santiago se nota mucha
crispación en el ambiente pareciera que
no es un terremoto solo lo que pasó sin
un terremoto económico y también un
terremoto social venía receta gilbertoan
de un una baja aprobación pero este
terremoto le pega muy duro sobre todo a
la reacción de las personas de Cara a
estas elecciones que se van a llevar a
cabo en mayo esas licencias de las que
usted hablaba al inicio que se dieron
para estas construcciones y que
finalmente no funcionaron y muchas
preguntas nuevamente de los turcos de
los ciudadanos están pagando un impuesto
a los sismos desde 1999 y se preguntan
qué está pasando con ese dinero o qué
pasó con ese dinero desde ese momento
cuando vemos que la respuesta a este
terremoto Pues no ha sido tan buena o ha
sido muy difícil Yo creo que por primera
vez la tiene un poco duro erdoan en
estas elecciones hay mucha crispación en
el ambiente y tal vez eso se vea
reflejado en los votos de las personas
puede que la oposición tenga bueno las
alcaldías de Estambul y por ejemplo de
ankara que son importantes pero sin duda
le pega duro a la imagen sobre todo el
presidente dearduana paso a preguntarle
justamente eso a Rafael Rafael Usted
cree que esta respuesta que ha dado el
gobierno Turco para esta emergencia le
va a pasar factura al presidente erdogan
de Cara a sus comienzos presidenciales
es probable aunque no debemos olvidar
que las elecciones están previstas para
el 14 de mayo y de aquí allí en tiempo
político es un mundo no es verdad que la
oposición ha conseguido consensuar una
candidatura con óvulo que es un líder
socialdemócrata pero que digamos no muy
conocido en el país no lo importante Yo
creo que es que si en este caso la
oposición ha decidido unirse todos los
partidos para plantarle cara Es verdad
que los alcaldes tanto de Estambul como
de ankara hubieran sido los candidatos
ideales Pero uno despierta cierta
reticencias en los sectores kurdos y el
alcalde de alcalde de Estambul Pues que
era el candidato ideal resulta que está
incapacitado porque está en un proceso
judicial de manera que lo que ha hecho
erdogan es meter digamos en problemas a
los candidatos más importantes que tenía
oposición y está jugando a ser digamos
en tiempos de crisis
no vale cambiar de caballo al cruzar el
río no que se diría Y entonces da la
impresión de que él quiere presentarse
como el hombre que puede levantar al
país de nuevo frente a adversarios que
todavía no tienen eficacia aprobada
Gonzalo su opinión de lo que ha sucedido
en Turquía a lo largo de este mes y está
coyuntura política tan particular que se
presenta allí en Turquía
definitivamente que correr el eje
tampoco ni la vista de la situación
económica en Turquía no uno de los
países más asediados en cuanto a la
inflación que como todos sabemos ha
cruzado al mundo entero después de la
pandemia y tras la invasión de Rusia
Ucrania pero Turquía mantiene un nivel
de inflación de aumento de precios
cercano al 85% anual que viene
arrastrando también malestar social que
excede claro está a la situación y a las
a las autorizaciones que se han ido
conociendo para la construcción de bueno
de todos los edificios que se han visto
después caídos por el terremoto Eh vale
remarcar también Más allá de que erdogan
terminó logrando este adelanto de las
elecciones para tratar de jugarlo a su
favor el propio presidente Turco quiso
previo al terremoto unos meses previos
allá por diciembre tomar una iniciativa
política aumentar los salarios mínimos
por ejemplo un cincuenta y cinco por
también devolver retribuciones a
funcionarios en un en cerca de un 30%
Pero esto no había sido suficiente para
modificar esa imagen negativa que el
presidente Turco venía arrastrando sobre
todo de los propios turcos y también
importante remarcar que la zona donde se
produjo el terremoto cerca del epicentro
del terremoto en la región sureste allí
cercano a Siri en la frontera con Siria
Mejor dicho era una región que se la
consideraba claves la considera clave
para el para el destino y el resultado
final de las elecciones Así que no hay
que perder de vista tampoco esa
situación en medio esta catástrofe
humanitaria y social producto del
terremoto quiero que hagamos el
ejercicio de ponernos en los zapatos de
un ciudadano Turco de a pie de la
normalidad de la cotidianidad de este
país y que tenga que pensar y poner en
balance la situación del país lo que ha
significado el gobierno de erdogan para
a lo largo de estos años ese intento de
su gobierno de darle a Turquía otra vez
ese peso internacional y esa fortaleza
sobre todo en los países cercanos en
donde en algún momento tuvo influencia
el Imperio otomano y la situación actual
y la posición que tiene Turquía en el
escenario internacional digamos en
cuanto a la guerra de Turquía de Ucrania
en donde Turquía ha jugado un papel muy
importante como una especie de bisagra
ante Oriente de occidente entre Rusia y
la Unión Europea y Estados Unidos para
buscar una negociación qué qué balance
ahí se puede hacer entonces de la
gestión de erdogan comienzo entonces
para hacer la ronda la inversa comienzo
entonces con Rafael para hacer ese
balance y Qué pesa más la presencia de
Turquía a nivel internacional el
desarrollo del país la presencia
internacional Cuál es el balance que
usted haría
Turquía es un país muy curioso porque es
un país que está por ejemplo en la otan
pero
digamos pero en el conflicto con Ucrania
se ha puesto se ha puesto de perfil Pero
hay una cosa que sí ha influido mucho
Turquía que es en el asunto del grano
gracias a Turquía que actuó como
mediadora consiguieron Los buques con
grano salir del país frente a una crisis
internacional alimentaria desde el punto
de vista de peso internacional tengo la
sensación de que no es demasiado si bien
es cierto que en el tema de Ucrania
digamos ha intentado jugar un papel
mediador dos menos cierto que su peso
específico en la estructura
internacional no es suficiente como para
mover la situación geoestratégica
Kelly su opinión sí se sabe que comparto
lo que dice Rafael obviamente ese
protagonismo que tiene en este
negociación que hicieron para sacar
finalmente los cereales de Ucrania que
se pudiera hacer las exportaciones y
también está metido obviamente en esas
negociaciones que se han llevado a cabo
en Siria por ejemplo que también está
metido el gobierno ruso ha hablado con
el presidente Vladimir Putin pero si uno
comparara obviamente lo que hace a nivel
internacional el presidente erdoan y ese
protagonismo o esa presencia que trata
de tener en los conflictos
internacionales pues tal vez no se
equipara a lo que necesita un ciudadano
Turco en estos momentos decía Gonzalo
ese terremoto afectó al 15% de la
población turca pero es la zona de más
pobreza que hay en el país creo que en
este momento a la hora de votar por
ejemplo para estas elecciones pensarían
mucho más los turcos en su vida diaria
en lo que está pasando que en resolver
obviamente problemas internacionales o
meterse en el rollo y en la pelea que
hay entre Ucrania y Rusia claro y
aterrizando un poco más ya lo de la
palabra Gonzalo aterrizando un poco más
la situación hay que mirar lo que ha
hecho todam a lo largo de estos años al
interior del país hay una extensa
censura en los medios de comunicación
hay una polarización en la ciudadanía
pues
vale la pena destacar también y después
de ese intento de golpe de estado pues
ha generado un montón de persecuciones a
nivel militar a nivel de los ciudadanos
también a nivel político la situación
interna es bastante tensa ya de por sí
en el país Gonzalo
sí efectivamente sumando a eso que sí
que es clave voy a contar una una
cuestión interna aquí nosotros en el
canal analizamos en el momento del
terremoto por ejemplo enviar a un equipo
hacia Turquía finalmente terminamos por
definir contratar a colaboradores que
allí trabajaban y el trabajo inclusive
Durante los momentos del rescate en los
primeros días después del terremoto no
fue sencillo justamente por el control
que existe y que se rige sobre la prensa
libre independiente allí en Turquía Así
que es un punto muy muy importante y
volviendo sobre la la Esfera
internacional y el mapa geopolítico no
quiero dejar de lado tampoco una
cuestión muy importante que es el
caucaso y es Armenia y azerbaiyán donde
sabemos que Turquía tiene un interés
histórico muy importante y una alianza
una cercanía muy muy fuerte con
azerbaiyán desde el momento en que
comenzó la invasión de Rusia Ucrania
también se fue intensificando ese
conflicto entre Armenia y azerbaiyán con
ataques con respuestas de ambos bandos y
muchos son los que especulan que ante el
debilitamiento de Vladimir Putin en el
caucaso y Por ende también en la
presencia entre estos dos países donde
hay dos mil skippers dos mil soldados
rusos que deberían mantener la paz entre
ellos o por lo menos buscar la paz entre
estos dos países está detrás la mano de
erdogan y de Turquía para tratar de
sacarle el peso relativo que Rusia tiene
en el caucaso y muchos son los que
especulan con que justamente ante este
debilitamiento de Rusia es Turquía quien
se metió más de lleno y más de fuerte en
el conflicto Para apoyar a cervellán
para aumentar tal vez el el esta
relación tensa que históricamente existe
con Armenia así que me parece que en el
mapa geopolítico por la importancia que
tiene el caucaso también para Turquía
este conflicto que está de lleno metido
el propio Turquía también es muy
importante para ir cerrando este para
avanzar con nosotros temas que tenemos
para el programa ve uno que hay como
muchas ramificaciones en la escena
internacional Turquía están muchos
escenarios al mismo tiempo de Cara a
esas elecciones esto como convendría
Kelly porque lo vemos como ve como dice
Gonzalo en el cáucaso con este conflicto
en la región de nagorno caravag que hay
que decir lleva casi
85-88 días completamente bloqueada por
por unos grupos ambientalistas que son
respaldados por hacer bailán y ahí
Turquía y Armenia Pues están tratando de
acercar posiciones a ver si Armenia
logra conseguir algo vimos la visita de
funcionarios armenios en territorio
Turco para tratar de distensionar un
poco allí la relación pero vemos también
a Turquía metida en Siria vemos también
la crisis o la atención permanente que
hay con Grecia esa relación tensa que
hay entre ankara y Bruselas con Rusia no
se define bien Cuál es la posición son
muchos escenarios sí como varios
tentáculos no Santiago y ese
protagonismo Que obviamente ha cobrado
como dice Gonzalo recepta gibby ardoán
por estos diálogos que ha entablado en
distintos escenarios hablábamos de lo
que pasa en Siria pero a la vez que está
negociando y Está tratando de arreglar
las cosas con el régimen sir y también
con el presidente Vladimir Putin está
atacando a los kurdos en el en esa parte
del país Entonces se viera como unas por
otras como tratando obviamente de hacer
presencia en el escenario internacional
pero haciendo o tratando de hacer las
cosas bien usted lo decía y lo ha
reseñado varios periodistas que han
denunciado Obviamente que no hay
libertad de expresión no hay libertad de
prensa en Turquía y muchos de estos
migrantes que han denunciado las cosas
que les han hecho cuando son trasladados
de otros países a Turquía que es un
acuerdo que finalmente se hicieron los
europeos con este país para atajar un
poco esa migración entonces claro hay
muchos escenarios muchos tentáculos pero
casi que todos no salen bien Esto
obviamente yo creo podría afectar a la
imagen de directamente en su país Rafael
para el cierre la conclusión de este
tema Cómo va entonces usted esta campaña
el presidente erdogan para lograr llegar
a una
reelección Será posible será reelecto lo
ve usted gobernando Turquía por unos
cuantos años más
las elecciones en Turquía según los
organismos internacionales son limpias
pero no justas que quiero decir quiero
decir que no se mete la mano en la en la
urna para cambiar los resultados pero sí
toda la presión de los medios de
comunicación de las radios de las
televisiones meter en la cárcel a los
disidentes presionar a los periodistas
presionar a los medios de comunicación
en general en sus directivas yo creo que
hace que digamos la población
reciba una información muy sesgada en
cualquier caso en esta ocasión la
información digamos viene opacada la
falta de información viene opacada por
el hecho de que están viviendo una
situación terrible con el tema de con el
asunto de del terremoto
yo me temo yo me Temo que finalmente
puede haber un descalabro en la posición
a pesar de que
han unifica una plataforma y me Temo que
erdogan podría ser reelegido
Pues nos quedan unos cuantos meses para
ver cuál es el desarrollo de esta
historia en Turquía en mayo lo sabremos
después de esos comicios presidenciales
avanzo con otro tema destacado de la
semana Y eso nos lleva hasta Francia que
fue testigo de la que tal vez ha sido la
mayor manifestación ciudadana en los
últimos años miles de personas Se
tomaron las calles en diferentes
ciudades del país bloquearon diferentes
sectores Como por ejemplo el de los
transportes ferroviarios solamente por
mencionar algunos para expresar su
descontento por esa propuesta a una
reforma al sistema de pensiones aun
cuando muchos no eran muy optimistas el
senado pues terminó aprobando este
polémico o plan y uno de los puntos
destacados el cambio en la edad de
jubilación que pasa de 62 a 64 años aún
así y pese al descontento de los
franceses y así no les guste Sigue
estando por debajo de la media Europea y
de muchos otros países desarrollados la
aprobación es tomada como una primera
Victoria lo podemos decir así del
presidente Manuel macó pero con un
altísimo costo político y esa va a ser
mi primera pregunta para Gonzalo hemos
visto protestas bloqueos demandas de
cambios en el sistema de pensiones y un
sinfín de reclamos que fueron los temas
de esta semana en Francia Gonzalo un
alto costo paga el presidente Manuel
Mako por este este proyecto de ley y de
reforma al sistema de pensiones
Sí definitivamente A ver no hay duda
tampoco que el presidente francés sabía
lo que se estaba enfrentando Al momento
de impulsar
esta controvertida modificación en el
sistema de pensiones Pero también es
cierto y sucede alrededor del mundo no
la el sistema de pensiones actual ante
una edad que es cada vez más alargada la
gente por suerte también vive cada vez
más tiempo Por ende también se se
extiende el tiempo de vida laboral
empieza a quedar recluido y los países
necesitan también para cuidar sus arcas
y sus finanzas y su sistema fiscal
necesitan ir poco a poco modificando
esta edad jubilatoria esto es a lo que
se enfrentó de Manuel macrón pero
también es importante y muchos en
Francia así lo resaltaban como una vez
más los sindicatos que muchas veces se
los creía olvidados o con poco poder
político y pulso social tal vez vuelven
a tomar la calle La manifestación que
vimos esta semana fue realmente
multitudinaria muchos dicen la más
multitudinaria desde las primeras que
empezaron si no me equivoco fue la sexta
y se espera que sigan creciendo de aquí
hasta el 12 de marzo que es la fecha en
la que se debería terminar por definir
este proyecto no hay duda de que
Emmanuel macronu un presidente
cosmopolita y globalizado podríamos
decir se está enfrentando también a
distintos sectores que miran con cierta
desconfianza tal vez está esta postura
del del presidente y y no no se abren
ante esta situación así que este es en
principio el panorama que hemos visto a
lo largo por lo menos de estas últimas
semanas que le impresiones de la
situación en Francia pues es
impresionante no lo que dice Gonzalo
tres coma cinco millones de personas que
finalmente salieron a las calles
obviamente dicen algo una oposición del
70% del país a esa reforma de las
pensiones de pasar de los 62 a los 64
años es el límite de la jubilación sabe
que sí le puede cobrar obviamente al
presidente macron por el lado político
es el protagonismo que ha tenido en los
últimos días o en los últimos meses
Marin le pen que es opositora que es de
derecha y Que obviamente va en contra de
la Reforma finalmente ha visto entonces
la derecha en esta reforma y en esta
crispación que hay entre los franceses
por esta propuesta del presidente macron
una salida para tener protagonismo
político por ese lado Pues podría tener
algunas consecuencias el gobierno de
macron sin duda él ha dicho obviamente y
lo lo ha dicho de frente a los
sindicatos Y de frente a los franceses
Vamos hasta el final con la reforma
porque se necesita y muchas críticas
obviamente de otros países europeos que
dicen como un poco los países tienen
vacaciones no tienen tanta edad de
jubilación pero responden los franceses
y los sindicatos en esas manifestaciones
bueno hemos peleado muchos años para
tener esta jubilación hemos peleado duro
le va a pegar duro obviamente a las
mujeres Entonces vamos a seguir es
incierto el desenlace pero dice el
presidente macron Vamos hasta el final
con la reforma Vamos hasta el final uno
de los puntos particulares es que no ha
habido ahí un acercamiento entre
sindicatos y gobierno Rafael su
impresión aquí yo creo que hay que
destacar este descontento que hay de los
franceses sin embargo rigen al
presidente macron nuevamente para
continuar en el poder Pero sí hay una un
peso grande entre los ciudadanos que les
cuesta como aceptar un poco el rumbo que
toma Francia y que va de la mano con el
presidente qué piensa usted
Sí lo que pasa es que generalmente nadie
en las elecciones a la presidencia
francesa nadie gana en la primera
vueltas todo el mundo generalmente se
decide las cosas en la segunda vuelta en
la segunda vuelta se pueden encontrar
como ocurrió la vez pasada entre Majo y
le pen y la ciudadanía francesa frente a
le pen prefiere votar a macron aunque no
sea digamos el personaje que él quisiera
que ellos quisieran no Marín le pen Está
sacando un buen rédito de esto porque
decía Kelly que tenía tirón en este en
este sentido ella se ha puesto muy de
perfil el mundo de
depend no ha salido a la calle nos está
movilizando pero todo el mundo sabe que
está en contra del aumento de la edad de
jubilación
yo creo que estoy de acuerdo también con
Kelly que macrón está dispuesto a llevar
hasta el final porque hay dos digamos
hay dos formas de hacer política En mi
opinión una bueno en general una es
hacer lo que uno cree que hay que hacer
y otra es hacer lo que dicen las
encuestas y creo que macron está por la
primera opción hacer lo que cree que hay
que hacer porque no solamente en Francia
en España en Italia en Alemania en toda
Europa como decía como decía Gonzalo se
pone de manifiesto que el sistema
Público de pensiones
necesita en este momento digamos un
cañonazo de vitaminas porque en caso
contrario el sistema Público de
pensiones se hundirá en los próximos
15-20 años la proyección que hace el
gobierno francés Es que al año 2030 el
descalabrado del sistema llegaría a unos
12.500 millones de euros serían las
pérdidas del sistema de pensiones allí
en Francia si no se hace una reforma
inmediata urgente como ha dicho allí El
Ejecutivo en París para ir cerrando este
tema a mí me llama mucho la atención que
los franceses no acompañan estas
reformas cada vez es más difícil para el
gobierno francés llevar adelante algún
tipo de cambios y de reformas lo vemos
desde que llegó el presidente al
gobierno y durante la crisis de la
pandemia fue muy difícil poder sortear
la situación que ha sido muy difícil y
sobre todo porque finalmente las
ciudadanos están respondiendo no sé si
esto sea un fenómeno Santiago que sea
mundial obviamente como vimos las
protestas en 2018-2019 cada país y cada
manifestación obviamente se iba dando
contra reformas de gobiernos que se
presentaban y las reformas tributarias y
las reformas pensionales parecen ser las
que más crispación obviamente generan
entre los ciudadanos si es como un
movimiento de respuesta si se ve
obviamente un cambio de los franceses
pero como decía obviamente Rafael le
Siguen votando a macronen Pero ahora sí
lo están criticando es decir ahora sí en
su cara le están diciendo esto no nos
gusta esto no va a pasar esto no tiene
sentido es como una expresión nueva como
que ayuda algunas medidas y algunas
maneras de que los ciudadanos finalmente
se manifiesten puede que se sigan
manifestando El problema es que
obviamente como decía Rafael el gobierno
hará lo que tenga que hacer para que
esto salga es una promesa de campaña de
macron en Rafael regreso con usted dejo
a Gonzalo de último en la ronda porque
vamos a pasar un tema Argentina que
quiero empezar a tratar con Gonzalo
retomo entonces la comunicación con
Rafael preguntándole si esto tiene algún
peso para Francia dentro de la Unión
Europea Francia es junto con Alemania
esos países llamados a tener cierto
liderazgo después de El fin del gobierno
de Angela Merkel y el retiro del Reino
Unido a través del brexit y este tipo de
zancadillas o piedras en el camino le
pueden entorpecer ese camino a Francia
para llegar a tomar el liderazgo que
muchos piden y reclaman al interior de
la Unión Europea
Pues yo creo que que en los últimos años
ese histórico entre esa locomotor
Europea de el eje Franco alemán se está
diluyendo mucho funcionaba mucho con
Ángela Merkel funcionó con sarcos y
también en su momento funcionó con
macron pero yo creo que ahora la
situación en Alemania ya no es de la la
capitalidad
Europea y
dudo que que se ponga de nuevo en marcha
ese eje fundamental sobre todo porque
Europa es digamos se ha vuelto muy
multipolar especialmente después de la
salida del Reino Unido del brexit le
puede ir bien le puede le puede convenir
a macron esto Probablemente sí
probablemente Alemania con solts ha
perdido mucho Mucho peso específico en
la Unión Europea y a lo mejor macron que
recuerden ustedes que fue el primero en
empezar a negociar con Putin para acabar
con la Guerra de Ucrania pues puede
resultarle cómodo en el conjunto de la
Unión Europea y creo que Alemania le
cobran mucho Esa falta o esa rapidez esa
falta de de tomar decisiones rápidas por
ejemplo con el tema de los tanques para
enviar a Ucrania hay Alemania digamos
que tuvo un poco como que el camino se
le iba complicando Bueno si les parece
bien dejamos el tema de Francia ahí nos
vamos hasta la región de América Latina
y nos vamos puntualmente hasta Rosario
provincia de Santa Fe en Argentina
ciudad que esta semana fue protagonista
en los medios debido a la llegada de
unos 1400 militares para brindar
seguridad la decisión para muchos tardía
la tomó el presidente Alberto Fernández
después de un ataque de grupos que están
ligados al narcotráfico a la familia del
jugador de fútbol Lionel Messi pero este
ataque que afectó a un ídolo nacional
puso sobre la mesa una realidad que
todos sabían que estaba pero que Tal
parece que no querían aceptar y es la
gran presencia de grupos
narcotraficantes en la provincia de
Santa Fe Argentina y todo lo que eso
conlleva claramente la violencia la
lucha entre las organizaciones
criminales solamente allí en Rosario se
han saldado ya con 95 muertos en lo que
va de El 2023 es un es un tema que está
empezando a hacer debatido en diferentes
sectores de la sociedad Argentina
justamente en un discurso a la nación el
presidente Alberto Fernández le declaró
digamos una lucha frontal contra el
narco argentino lo que no sabe el
presidente lo que Tal parece que no sabe
Es que esto es como una enfermedad que
es lenta Pero segura y que no se
extermina sino que lo digan países como
por ejemplo Colombia y México que llevan
décadas luchando contra los grupos
ligados al narcotráfico y es una lucha
Pues que llega y hace todo el esfuerzo
para mantenerse ahora sí le doy la
palabra Gonzalo que lo tenía un poco
relegado pero justo quería comenzar este
tema con usted porque pues no es una
novedad que Rosario sea una ciudad
afectada por el tema del narcotráfico lo
que tal vez no sabía la gente no sabía
muchas personas es que Argentina es un
punto estratégico del narcotráfico
latinoamericano internacional y esta
lucha frontal que lanza al presidente
pues es un poco ambiciosa no
sí efectivamente la introducción que que
hiciste fantástica y resume a la
perfección la situación actual aquí en
Argentina desde hace años sabemos que la
provincia de Santa Fe y particularmente
Rosario es núcleo central de
distribución y fabricación y elaboración
de drogas y distribución hacia todo el
país y hacia distintos puntos también
del mundo y así en Rosario operan las
bandas narco criminales más peligrosas
de la Argentina esa cifra que diste vos
es implacable más de un muerto por día
desde que empezó este año más de un
muerto por día y el ataque contra la
familia de Antonella roccuzzo al
supermercado fue solo una una aler solo
un mensaje pero esta semana también
despertó un fuerte repudio el asesinato
de un chiquito de tan solo once años que
estaba jugando al fútbol en uno de los
barrios más peligrosos podríamos decir
de Rosario donde operan estos grupos
narco criminales y recibió un disparo
por parte de un sicario que se había
enfrentado con otro de los narcos que
allí estaban y este niño falleció 11
años tenía fue después de esa situación
en la que el presidente Alberto
Fernández decidió enviar mil
cuatrocientos efectivos Pero nos tenemos
que remontar hacia años atrás cuando el
gobernador de la provincia de Santa Fe
Omar perotti ya le había pedido y venía
exigiendo tanto al presidente como al
Ministerio de seguridad que es quien se
debería encargar de la seguridad que
ayuden colaboren Y que le brinden más
asistencia a la provincia porque
indefectiblemente la capacidad
presupuestar y la capacidad de de
sistema de seguridad que tiene no es
suficiente para detener a los narcos y
una pregunta también se abre aquí y lo
dejo también para discutir entre
nosotros la convivencia de la política
nada de lo que sucede en Rosario y lo
que vino aumentando los últimos años
puede lograrse sin la convivencia
política como hemos visto También en
estos otros ejemplos que también hemos
mencionaste alrededor de América Latina
bueno Kelly impresiones importante lo
que sucede allí en Argentina
compleja la situación de seguridad muy
difícil La pregunta sería si la
respuesta finalmente es la
militarización de la zona porque en
México hemos visto casos y aquí en
Colombia también donde finalmente llevar
a los militares y a los soldados no ha
funcionado para controlar el
narcotráfico y el microtráfico que
también es una cosa que va de pequeño a
grande pero también es muy interesante
no sé si Gonzalo obviamente lo haya
mencionado o lo sepa en lo que decía el
ministro de justicia en Argentina que
era un poco desligar a los que están en
las prisiones en las cárceles a los que
están afuera que hay una red operativa
entre ellos que sirve para que esta este
narcotráfico siga funcionando en un poco
lo que pasa con Ecuador y ese fenómeno
que hemos visto de cómo desde las
cárceles los narcotraficantes siguen
manejando obviamente los negocios y
siguen Traficando pero muy difícil la
situación en Rosario y no sé si la
respuesta finalmente sea la
militarización Si eso funcione para
bajar no solo el tráfico sino las
muertes más de 90 muertes es absurdo a
mí lo que me llama la atención Rafael
Kelly Gonzalo es que ahora resulta que
descubrieron que Argentina era parte de
las redes de narcotráfico internacional
cuando sabemos que de gobiernos atrás
pues prácticamente se se abrió puertas
para no abrieron las puertas pero no se
hacía nada para evitarlo Rafael su
opinión todos los que hemos vivido en
Argentina en Buenos Aires y en mi caso
durante seis años sabemos verdad Gonzalo
que hace un millón de años los jóvenes
morían por fumar el Paco que el Paco es
como como sabes bien es digamos El
recuerdo que queda de cocinar La la
cocaína no
me pregunto ahora es
yo recuerdo en noviembre murió mataron
una niña en una balacera en febrero un
bebé que apenas tenía 2 años
pillaron a una vendedora de cocaína que
era portera de un colegio si no llega a
ser porque sale el nombre de Messi las
cosas subirán
seguirían como están ahora
o ha sido la internalización del nombre
de Lionel Messi lo que ha hecho que el
gobierno de Buenos Aires decida enviar
allí a militares y policía y yo creo que
se rompe además uno de los logros que
había conseguido Argentina en los
últimos en los últimos tiempos no que es
digamos la separación que existía entre
la defensa nacional y la seguridad
interior que con los tiempos que
ocurrieron en Argentina con la dictadura
me parece una me pareció muy importante
esa separación el enviar a la al
ejército a Rosario no me parece una
buena medida Aunque sospecho como
sospechas tú muy bien Gonzalo Y es que
la policía está metida o buena parte de
ella en los trapicheos del Narco qué es
lo que pasa y es el escenario que vemos
en otros países donde ya la corrupción
que parte de los grupos narcotraficantes
pues va permeando diferentes sectores de
la de la sociedad y de los sectores
políticos y y pues solamente llegan allí
jugosas cantidades de dinero para poder
mover sus tentáculos y mantener el
mercado vamos llegando ya la parte final
del programa Me quedan pocos minutos
pero quiero ir cerrando el tema de
Argentina de lo que puede venir si
estamos ante un escenario similar a lo
que estamos viendo en México donde hay
episodios de violencia o si estamos
viendo que simplemente se va a despertar
esta lucha frontal entre el estado
argentino y estos grupos de narcotráfico
allí en Santa Fe en la provincia de
Santa Fe dada esta declaración de lucha
que ha hecho el presidente Fernández a
pocos meses de terminar su mandato con
saldo
sí es es importante lo que sí sí es muy
importante también pensarlo en un tono
de campaña este año la Argentina en
octubre tiene elecciones presidenciales
donde todavía no se sabe quién será el
candidato oficialista algunos especulan
con que sea Alberto Fernández y no por
nada también esta situación este ataque
a la familia de Messi ocurrió ahora
mucho la lectura también política que se
hace alrededor de esto de decir bueno
por fin como como bien decíamos recién
Por fin se le Presta atención a la
situación rosario yo soy un tanto
escéptico en pensar que haya una un
enfrentamiento y una intención de lograr
desterrar Y lograr frenar por completo
el narcotráfico porque está muy metido
la raíz en Santa Fe en Rosario y lo que
se ve en esa provincia es muy similar a
lo que se ve inclusivo que se ha visto
más aún en Colombia y México es muy
difícil con tan solo mil cuatrocientos
efectivos que se envíen a la calle
tratar de sacar de raíz una situación
que viene desde hace años como decía los
grupos en las cárceles con mandando todo
tienen una red de narcotráfico muy
establecida a través de sicarios y
pequeños proveedores Entonces esto no es
algo que se pueda solucionar de un mes a
otro ni siquiera que se va a poder
solucionar de aquí a octubre cuando son
las elecciones sino que se necesita un
proceso y una decisión política a largo
plazo para para un minuto para finalizar
el programa quiero cerrar preguntándole
a Rafaela Gonzalo temas que van a tener
ustedes en sus redacciones a lo largo de
la próxima semana Kelly Bueno estamos
pendientes de chile Santiago porque
obviamente empezó este proceso de la
nueva Constituyente para elegir a los
comisionados Entonces estamos un poco
pendiente y de ese revés que tuvo el
presidente Gabriel boric finalmente con
la reforma tributaria de esta semana que
no pasó Rafael sus temas Israel Israel
sin duda alguna la situación es
tremendamente conflictiva el ejército
está ya muy preocupado con la deriva
autoritaria que está tomando el nuevo
gabinete compuesto por
ultraderechistas y Ultra ortodoxos y yo
creo que a él en la próxima semana va a
dar juego internacional y para el cierre
Gonzalo sus temas y aquí en todo
noticias estamos trabajando fuerte las
últimas semanas con respecto a la crisis
migratoria que cada vez más se ve en las
puertas de Europa las políticas que está
adoptando Italia la política que tomó el
propio sunak en el Reino Unido Así que
estamos siendo muy de cerca la situación
de la crisis migratoria y la cantidad de
los millones los miles y millones de
personas que huyen de la guerra de la
destrucción hubo un futuro mejor con
tickets directamente hacia la muerte
Gonzalo Rafael Kelly les agradezco mucho
por haber estado con nosotros aquí en el
programa la producción estuvo a cargo de
Laura garzón y la producción de
invitados estuvo a cargo de Tania
Herrera Pueden seguir dejando sus
comentarios a través de las redes
sociales sigan con France 24